the operation side was essentially um
tremendous boredom punctuated by moments
of sheer terror
okay because you basically sit around
and hope nothing breaks and then the
moment it does
you know the fire bell rings and it's
now you know 9 29
and the market opens in one minute and
you know clearly if it doesn't open
you're a complete failure
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
imagine what it's like being responsible
for part of the infrastructure that
makes the new york stock exchange tick
well meet andrew bach global financial
technologies leader
with over 30 years of experience andy
specializes in network and
telecommunications
security and financial technologies andy
has substantial expertise to lead
strategic communication technological
planning
to achieve business goals by
prioritizing technology initiatives
and coordinating the evaluation
deployment and management
of current and future technologies as a
global financial technologies leader
he established strategic direction led
all aspects of technology development
and implementation
and provided formal supervision and
coaching for the architectural security
and infrastructure functions
while setting the vision to inspire and
drive continuous improvements
andrew f bach welcome to 20 minute
leaders how you doing andy
it's great day i'm glad to be here i'm
really excited to have you here i'm
really excited we made this work
because i'm really excited to pick your
brain into
you know an industry and a world that i
don't know much about
uh it sounds really complicated it
sounds like you do really important
things
and i'm excited to learn more about you
because we had a really fun chat
a while back and and and i got
introduced to this really really cool
person that i can't wait to introduce
a lot of my friends and and colleagues
too andy
tell me a little bit about yourself what
what do you do and
how do you see sort of your journey
oh it's been a fun journey and and i
think the most important point there is
fun
uh technically challenging but then
again i'm a techno geek at heart so i
enjoy my technology
so that's been good um i would like to
say that it's always been brilliantly
planned
and skillfully executed as opposed to a
fair amount of serendipitous good luck
but i'll go with good luck um in terms
of
job opportunities and also more
importantly meeting the right people
along the way
has really been fun so what do i do um
in in you know two minutes or less i
started off as
a coming out of engineering school
convinced i was going to design
uh analog integrated circuits um that
died quickly when i went to my first job
where i had the pleasure of designing
digital signal processing for sonar
systems
for the world's navies so anything you
want to know about identifying either a
whale that has
some issues or an incoming torpedo i can
run you through the mathematics
not so sure it's a useful skill but it
certainly was interesting at the time
learning it
and doing it wow so that was part of it
yeah from there i really branched out
and went to this thing called
communications
which not communications is people tend
to think of it today you know that thing
that you do with
you know the pressers and the media and
all that but rather
networking telephone circuits and back
in the day it was a lot of telephone
circuits it was about
mapping all your data that you wanted to
send from one computer to another onto
some sort of tele you know
basically a conventional phone circuit i
mean to show my age
i can remember having a conversation
about upgrading modems to 192 kilobits
per second
wow high speed transmission at the time
yeah
high speed so that's going pretty far
back in time
wow yep yeah and as i
lucked out i had taken a job at a
company called
securities industry automation
corporation sayak
sure it's a company no one has ever
heard of and never will probably
but if you're in the financial industry
they were a wholly owned subsidiary the
new york and american stock exchanges at
the time
and their job was to provide all the
technology to the exchanges
and i joined them started off in their
communications department that became
the
you know communications engineering and
you know fast forward
some 26 years and i wound up being you
know the senior vice president
and global head of network services
which
really translated to i had an opport
anything had anything to do with
communications anyway whether it was in
the data center
the networking precision timing using
atomic clocks
the cell phone that one of the
executives accidentally dropped into the
toilet in the men's room all of that was
my problem wow from beginning to end
including the operations got help
gotta love those calls at three o'clock
in the morning
it has its moments i the operation side
was essentially
um tremendous boredom
punctuated by moments of sheer terror
okay because you basically sit around
and hope nothing breaks and then the
moment it does
you know the fire bell rings and it's
now you know 9 29 and the market opens
in one minute
and you know clearly if it doesn't open
you're a complete failure
so wow wow you know the operation side
had its challenges
the architecture and the engineering
side was phenomenal i
you got to build some of the best
technology around
so that's what made it really exciting
now you really was um
you had to i mean what people never
realized is that the financial industry
as a whole
is the single largest consumer of
technology
and early adopter for a collection of
very
you know conservative operationally
conservative people
it was amazing how much technology would
adopt on the bleeding edge
and you know there's fun facts you know
there were more phone lines
in by 18 96 or so there were more phone
lines going into the new york stock
exchange that were in all of the new
york city
wow early adopters of phones huh
so and it's just you know pick your
favorite exchange pick your favorite
brokerage house and you'll find lots of
examples there
at the exchange we were the first ones
to use tablets and i'm not talking about
a tablet from apple we're talking about
this
hacked together contrived piece of
electronics that was custom built for us
on the first wireless protocols it was
amazing
uh first flat panel displays were flat
panel touch screen displays
that were actually originally introduced
into slaughterhouses
and why did we use those because they're
incredibly rugged
in a slaughterhouse at the end of the
day they come out with a fire hose and
wash everything down with salt and
chlorine water
so we figured it might hold up for a
little bit wow in our environment
because you had a lot of
very impassioned people on the floor
yeah
i bet now andrew i believe trade didn't
go their way they would put something
through it i really want you to
to explain to you a little bit about you
know the new york stock exchange and
you're
i'm i'm imagining myself in a position
like you're describing here
being responsible for a lot of the
communication the networking the
telecommunication that needs to go on
to power what you know
today millions of people around the
world are taking part in
every second that must be
a big responsibility
it is um fortunately it's shared amongst
a few people
at the senior level one i had the
communications
environment i had a counterpart who had
all of security
another counterpart who had all of i'll
put in quotes databases
another counterpart who had all of the
server farms
and you had to work together as a very
close team obviously because everything
was interconnected
but you really had to be a leading
technology expert in that respective
vertical
in my world in the communications i had
to deliver quite literally millions of
messages per second
with for all practical purposes 100
reliability
and you had to do it in there was always
the running competition to see how fast
you could do it
and we were down to comfortably you know
into the millionths of a second wow
with through with and striving to go
lower
that's just that's just incredible now
putting me in that situation
you get to work every day and you're
mentioning on one hand the
you know the perhaps not the
apprehension it sounds like but but
but i'm sure that it was it wasn't as
dramatic but you know the bill ringing
and
you know is everything today going going
to work well how at the same time do you
balance
making sure that everything runs
smoothly to continuing to improve
and allotting space strategically
for both maintenance but also making
sure that the new york stock exchange is
always using the most up-to-date
technologies with the best
infrastructure
and the best communication
it's a very tough balance and you also
need
working with you or for you your team
that's extremely good at you need a very
strong leader on the operation side
who really focuses on the day by day
minute by minute
is it up and running and dealing with
that then you need
the people that are just looking forward
you have a couple that are the you know
the true pie in the sky
folks that are searching out
you know new technology that might have
some applicability
in the next six months to a year or two
years out
and then you've got to have the core
team of designers that will then take
the dreams of the the lead architect
and combine it with the realities of the
operations manager who says
it's not going online unless i can run
it successfully
and try to meld those two together and
in between
you need to whatever you set for your
goals and expectations for today
you know you look at your calories okay
i'm gonna have six meetings yeah no
you know you got six but you're going to
lose two because you have to deal with
the unexpected stuff that popped up you
know there's always something that'll
pop up somewhere someone
did something or there's an operational
issue or there's a technology challenge
and it just
you've got to carve out an extra hour
for that so the trick
to the job was to remain remarkably
flexible
which sounds difficult you had a general
sense a general plan
of attack but boy you had to adapt real
quick and i'm guessing that as you go
through
you know the the many other positions
that you've held this is just
one of many experiences that you that
you've gotten to to be had you know
partially you know the vp and chief
architect of financial services and
juniper
and a phenomenal company a chairperson
of you know
of wonderful organizations and and
member of advisor of wonderful
organizations
what do you extract you know from a
technologically leadership
position what what are some things that
you've
found useful as you've gone through your
your journey in terms of being a good
leader in the technology world
there's a couple uh i i i think you know
thinking back on it
i i got lucky or or maybe it was
brilliant planning i don't know which
you know
i'll go with luck um i got the new york
stock exchange experience was the buy
side
i was always buying technology which
means i got to beat up on vendors
regularly
for their product and you know sort of
tell them what they should build on the
juniper side it was the exact opposite i
was on the sell side trying to convince
people that they we
you know should use our architecture our
technology
and of course they would beat up on me
but i
think some of the key aspects especially
on the leadership is one listen to your
people
you know clearly hire the best give them
the freedom to succeed
which means you've got to put a safety
net under them when they don't
um have faith in them because they
really are good
okay very rarely do you hire poorly
you know you go through a normal
interview process and most people work
out well
and then some work out exceptionally
well and on a very rare occasion do you
run into a dud
but that's few and far between thank
goodness
but the key is to let them give them the
uh the room
to strive give them the room to go
invent their own ideas
you know dog you can't be that
micromanager who you know
stays right on top of everything they're
doing just post the task and say i'll
see you next week on that one and if
you've got some questions by all means
happy to sit and talk to you about it
but you ought to be able to go figure
this out
and it's remarkable what innovative
solutions
people will produce when you let them
give them the freedom to do that
and then sometimes also accept the fact
that
they'll come up with a bright idea
you'll agree that it's a bright idea
and it turns out to be wrong it's a dud
so
the answer is you've got to leave that
safety net in that cushion that says hey
you know you got it right eight times
and two times it was a dud that's the
way it goes
right you know it's especially on the
technology front because you're going to
try a new technology
and the key phrase there is try and you
know
you're smart you follow it so you've got
a sense that it's really going to be
successful but once in a while
yeah for all the best intentions it just
wasn't you know a perfect fit for
whatever reason
so be accepting of the failures that's
almost
that's almost as important as
congratulating the success
and i think the big thing is don't be
afraid
to acknowledge success if your team does
something good
it's all them right just remind them
that they're
you know thank them for making you look
good as a manager
that's really nice that's what's really
about i love that sentence thank them
for making you look good as a manager
that's that's a really nice way yeah
because i'm only going to be as good
as they are at the end of the day right
right now how do you empower
i'm not personally go ahead
i was going to say i'm not on the front
line making every single micro decision
so i've got to trust and enable them to
make all the right decisions right
that's what it comes down to and now how
do you empower people and then clear the
way in front of them
how do you empower them to to do exactly
that to you know you're clearing the way
in front of them
in one in one place but you know it's
easier said than done right i mean you
can read a lot of leadership books about
yeah don't be a micromanager and empower
people and give them room and
congratulate and accept the failures but
at the end
and a lot of it comes down to nuances
right it comes down to how they perceive
you
as a leader and how you really mean and
not just you know what do you say but
also how you respond and how you act on
the day-to-day life
i see that a lot right
yeah that's true so there's the
mechanical part of it which is if they
want to go explore something make sure
that you
secure the funding for them uh
you shield them from whatever other
management entities are there
in terms of you know people questioning
them you want
valid challenges and valid objections
but at some point you want to make sure
that it doesn't cross the line to they
just like to beat on your people
right for whatever reason and then
you've got to step in and say excuse me
don't beat on him
i'll take it i get paid the big bucks
you can beat on me
okay i'm a professional whipping boy for
my people
you have to do that you've got to defend
and protect them right and
that's true of any organization that's
not unique to anyone
but the more higher pressure the
organization is the more likely you're
found
you know find someone who's going to
come back and really go after
your people right so you have to do that
the other thing
is and you've got to communicate this
over and over again
is you're available there for them and
you're there to support them and make
sure they understand that
make sure they understand that it's okay
to come in and ask the dumb question
if it's i explain something to you and
then you know 15 minutes they come back
and say i didn't understand a word you
said
okay let's go back through it again so i
have to be open to the fact that they
didn't get it
but they have to be you have to instill
in them a sense that it's okay to come
back and ask the question again yes
i was just about to say that and also
it's
yeah yeah they um they they have to
learn that it's okay to question you
the last thing you want is someone who
you know you say oh maybe you can do it
that way and they take that
as an absolute directive and you really
need to instill in them and convince
them
that no you're you're allowed to come
back and go excuse me boss that's a
remarkably stupid idea you want to try
that again
it's okay i mean you know you got to
learn how to and i'll use the
cliche you've got to learn how to park
your ego at the door
right right and and the trick is
managing those egos because we all have
egos
but when you're in a very high
performing organization
with very skilled and very talented
people that translates to phenomenal
egos
i mean you think about it you're in a
position where you wake up every morning
and you believe that you're going to do
a billion share trading day
with no problem and the mere fact that
you think you can do that every day
already says you've got one heck of an
ego wow and that's
you know before you even get your first
cup of coffee in you right
definitely now as you go through and you
look through
the advancements of technology and
you've seen a lot of them
and going back all the way to the high
transmission
intern that we talked about before are
you surprised
is it weird for you to see how fast
things are are moving do you feel that
you're
you've experienced a lot of these
technological invasions because you've
really
seen you know in execution these
technologies
and all their phases until now you know
ever since you started
you know it's you know what it sounds
like quite some time ago
i not overly surprised
uh and maybe that you know goes a little
bit back to the era in which my parents
grew up
when my father was born there were no
planes in the sky
and yet he saw a man walk on the moon
okay well if you think about the
technology innovation just in that range
that he lived through
and the other thing that you need to
accept is
with every technological innovation that
we
come up with as a society that
accelerates our next technological
innovation you can always trace back
what someone invented today to the prior
three or four things
that came before it and that pace just
continues to accelerate and it has
conservatively for the last you know at
least four or five hundred years
historically okay i mean you think about
it we started with
you know sharpening a p developing iron
so we could develop a size so we could
harvest wheat
in the field and somehow we've turned
that into
a you know a john deere combine that
sweeps across an acre of land and you
know five minutes or whatever they do
it's incredible wow you know those giant
thrashing machines you see nowadays
so pick any space you want and there's
massive innovation
um it's human nature you know we
innovate or we die
at the end of the day yeah and i think
that
yesterday i'm not surprised by it yeah
today we're saying
you know the things that i'm observing
around and
i grew up in a different era i grew up
in an era where i'm i'm born into
i'm born into a smartphone and i'm
seeing it transform
every single day and i get just so
excited about thinking how it transforms
but what i
also question a lot is you know is this
question of leadership or
what we've been talking about when
you're when you when you've
harnessed this idea of technological
innovation but now your job is to
empower others to do it
and and you had to do that in you know
phenomenal circumstances
that i get to talk very rarely to people
who've
gotten the chance to do it in in a
similar circumstances
or of similar intensity or nature that's
just really really exciting for me to
hear those insights
i do have a few fun questions for you if
you're ready for them
sure go ahead okay we'll start off easy
we'll get a little bit weirder along the
way
a favorite subject in middle or high
school
oh gosh um you're not going to believe
this it would be engineering
it would be technology um doesn't make
sense
i'll phrase this i'll phrase it somewhat
politely i popped out of my mother as a
fully developed
engineer i mean it was i was born an
engineer it's as simple as that i love
it
i mean yeah it is what it is
one of your role models you know some
people are born with vast musical
talents right
someone comes out and all of a sudden
they're playing the piano by the
time they're eight years old well that
certainly wasn't me i have absolutely no
musical talent
but hand me a slide rule appropriate for
that era
and i was off and running i love it one
of your role models
or somebody that inspires you
this there's i've had the pleasure of
having a few
but i think the one that's most notable
was uh my
last boss at the new york stock exchange
was a phenomenal gentleman that was a
pleasure to work for
and inspirational now first of all he
was
remarkably brilliant to say the least um
he made me look like i you know couldn't
even tie my shoelaces
but he never tell you that he he'd never
you wouldn't he wouldn't brag about it
but when you start to talk to him you'd
hear little things like oh yeah you know
i did my
you know chemical degree and you know
undergraduate graduate master's degree
got a phd in this and i
got a second master's in that and the
third master's in that and i'm fluent in
six languages
and then he'd go from there and i'm like
oh my gosh now
again he wasn't this you know you didn't
have the swelled head and you know i am
great and perfect
it was like having a conversation like
you and i are having today just a fun
chat
but boy don't challenge him because he
could run circles around you
any day amazing yeah he could out-talk
you and out-read you
anytime he wanted to amazing and if you
worked hard at it you could finally get
you know tease that out of him but he
was such a pleasure to work for and
very inspirational and again he was the
one that talked about
giving people the freedom to succeed and
accept the fact that once in a while
it's going to be a dud and it was
he was quite the character he's still
rattling around the industry having a
good time
uh which is great and he also was highly
diversified he wasn't just
focused on the job he also did some
teaching on the side which then i
started to teach on the side which
helps round out your career and
objectives again it's not
about showing off your ego it's about
learning from the students
it's really fun to try to explain a
technical subject to a group of people
who are interested in learning
but they don't get it and it really
reminds you and grind
it grounds you in how you need to
explain things
there was nothing more educational for
me than actually teaching a few classes
at the college level i love it
last question three words that you would
use to describe yourself
sure
so i i thought about this a little bit
uh because
that question does pop up from time to
time from other people too
i guess one of them obviously is techno
geek um i was born and raised an
engineer from the get-go
it is what it is you know like i said
some people are master cello players i'm
a really good you know i'm an engineer
that's what i am second
and well let me not say second
in no order of preference family
it's about raising the family caring for
the family
having that commitment to other people i
have been blessed with a wonderful wife
two fantastic kids throwing a grandson
now
you know it's all good stuff and what's
amazing is we'll hang out together
uh there are many tales that i won't
recount because it's probably
inappropriate
of going drinking with my kids
ah okay yeah
so much so that maybe it was one of the
kids that had to drive me home on
occasion that sort of thing
but that's about you know a fan a family
bond also
um again not by brilliant planning as
opposed to it just sort of evolved that
way and you sort of learn
along the way but you see these families
that just you know they don't get along
they don't talk
yeah this this family's you know
fortunately quite the opposite
and then i guess i i gotta throw in just
for fun uh a little bit of a wino i am
definitely cultivating the wine side of
my um hobbies and business
so i've got a nice little wine cellar
going um
i've put on my bucket list that i'm
going to get to all the wineries on long
island and try all their wines
well there's about 70 wineries each one
puts out about 10 to 15 wines you can do
the math
i'm going to be drinking for a long time
sounds it sounds phenomenal and andy
i want to thank you so much for joining
me this was just a lovely insightful
i really enjoyed it um and i appreciate
all the insight and your time it was
really great thank you
thank you and i had a great time also my
pleasure take care